all right everybody it's time for drew's
news your daily good news trust fall
where rest assured we'll always catch
you
with me at the desk the co-pilot who
catches me every single day ross
matthews
[Applause]
are you ready to jump
come here come on you want me to catch
you yeah ready ready ready to fall i'm
gonna catch you three two oh god
oh wow wow she falls for it every time
that was like you like that dirty man
yeah with really i was really worried i
was gonna drop you i know i was
i was like worried about my ankle you
get older you get so cautious but i got
your back girl
i would i trust you with everything oh
ditto love you all right well i love you
more okay first um we've got some news
for all our die-hard fans of the crown
out there anybody a die-hard fan of the
am
crown
i totally am well season five doesn't
come out till this fall but we've
already got
scoop on season six bustle reports that
the 60
bustle reports that the sixth season
will be the last and casting has already
started on the hunt for a young kate
middleton
season six covers
1997 to the early 2000s and that's when
william first met kate at university who
would you pick to play a young kate
middleton yeah okay thank you for asking
because i thought a lot about this and
um okay carrie mulligan you guys know
carrie mulligan oh yeah she would be
great
oh and she kind of the dimples and look
at that well and she looks like her
they've both got very angular beautiful
classic features i mean she's they're
both stunning do you have a better one
well i have three oh okay
so i went triptych i created a little
bit of a mood board here are mine um we
have the beautiful olivia rodrigo
belle paoli
and daisy edgar jones
great great so a little variety in there
different styles different looks but all
women that i admire well i also thought
about um prince william mm-hmm and what
about taran egerton
right oh my god perfect isn't that great
cassie look at him rocket man
kingsman
you know
i'm mad though because
i feel like why are you ending this i
mean we've got fergie we've got oh god
prince andrew we've got you know the
queen is still alive we've got harry and
megan what why are they ending it what
are you doing why
i don't get it either the crown is the
queen and she's still alive through all
of it and it does also show how
the prim and proper evolution into like
where we are at today this is
fascinating i don't want the crown to
end i don't either and i think that i
think that the family is having
conversations now they've never had
before you know this family has been
think about
just what it looked like when harry and
megan got married and how different that
was for the royal family i want to hear
the behind the scenes of that i would
just like to see where the series starts
where it's very buttoned up and it is
all about how it looks into opening it
all up and not sweeping everything i'm
with you i think it'd be fascinating
maybe they'll be watching right now and
they'll change their minds
[Music]